no it's
hard for them they've got all the same
emotions as everybody else and they want
to see them on and they don't know where
she is and
um you know they just desperately want a
home and I guess that's that's all
they're asking all the time is
where is she and is she coming to home
yeah
and everyone just wants to be able to
give an answer yes which we can't do
obviously which is probably the most
difficult thing for Paul
one of the most difficult things for him
trying to find an answer to all the
questions why we don't have any answers
he was kind and she was one of us you
know she's a mom she's a friend and a
partner and a great caring person you've
got lots of Hope and we're not going to
let go of that and we'll keep going
we'll just keep going